[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous sommes réunis pour
thesis des abscisses tmx c'est la
deuxième édition que l'on organisme au
sein de liberté systemx où l'on donne
l'occasion à nos doctorants 30
dr en bas il y en a dix parmi ces 32
présenté en trois minutes
leur thèse devant un public ouvert de
façon à leur permettre de s'exprimer et
de comprendre comme le fait l'université
paris saclay
sur le thème ma thèse en 180 secondes au
jeu cette année nous faisons cet
exercice en collaboration et en
coopération avec les tv des com qui
possède aussi des doctorants sur des
sujets en proximité puisque ça tourne
principalement autour de la mobilité et
du véhicule autonome donc cette
organisation comprend à la fois une
table ronde qui nous permet de
comprendre quelles sont les
particularités des trains doctorants
dans un institut de recherche par
rapport à un cif ou par rapport à 1
doctorant directement dans une
université et de présenter ces sujets de
thèse est déroulé l'ensemble des
présentations pour chacun des doctorants
on a aussi un jury qui va nommer je
dirais la meilleure présentation ainsi
qu'un prix du jury qui chaque personne
qui a assisté va pouvoir voter pour son
meilleur candidat
le gagnant à l'honneur d'être le gagnant
de cette édition et pour continuer sa
thèse avec encore plus de confiance et
de respect de ses collègues
donc il s'agit surtout d'un exercice en
propre pour faire connaître expliqué sa
thèse et tout le travail qui a été fait
en préparation par rapport à ça et
surtout le point intéressant de d'amener
à exprimer techniquement une thèse en
trois minutes et dans l'intéressant un
public large et qui n'a pas forcément le
même niveau technologique et
scientifique du dr
[Musique]